[Music]
it is time
i have an announcement to make hold up
hola
no no no
the outporn is here i'll unbox it in a
second let's get into the memes
[Music]
come there we go
hood's reaction almost made me cry it
was perfect
[Music]
go check out bad history amazing video
they nailed it
oh we got some memes about it this is
good for meme economy
great people in the movie based on a
true story
picture of the actual person in the end
i know the joke and i don't appreciate
it and i don't agree with it
thank you plus i didn't have the bit
where's the beer
huh you failed bad history
what is this i am not seeing this meme
oh
yeah did not expect that
imagine getting that for your wife
marzia i just had
to explain to felix what pup that's
sharing
i don't need that i know sex
nobody teacher at the beginning i'm
angry all right too far
teachers at the beginning of online
classes turn turn on the camera
is that what they do i don't get it i'm
not a child hey felix
it's the airplane lid one last time oh
god i forgot to reply
i'm not logged into reddit i'm sorry i
guess i found a big fan
cringe is that a pewdiepie fan good
cringe dude
oh god oh that's weird pewdiepie and his
son
i heard he was like a father to him so
someone took my photo made me
with my dad and made me old and my dad
young and that's that's just weird
stop it knock knock dave who there
dudes hike dave haiku oh didn't know you
like japanese poetry
i'm 30 now i make dad jokes deal with it
you know this package is surprisingly
light oh
that is second night now i'm 30. hey
y'all ever mess with me not gonna say
anything else for that
i love when they put like a sign not to
use a knife to open the package i'm like
how am i gonna get it open then punch it
does it make you guys anxious what if
this is not the outboard i'm gonna be so
disappointed
sorry tambourine power you're irrelevant
what the hell is this is that that
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] it's flexible
i think i got a better one than uh no it
isn't flexible never mind
jesus i can't even fit this in this room
hey i got to do it again hey come come
at me bro
oh here's some outfits i was worried
they weren't not going to include that
but i think if you spend over 2 000 on a
[ __ ] instrument
oh my god is this gonna
yeah it might be able to fit holy [ __ ]
it's so big
oh i forgot the mouth please okay okay
back to the memes i'll blow i'll blow it
at the end of the video
[Applause]
that's not a pewdiepie intro that's
someone else's video i've seen this
channel pewdiepie the y reaction
to your list pewdiepie actually tearing
up marcia check you once
big peepee huge peepee good meme ha ha
small pp i don't like this what the [ __ ]
yes you get enough upvotes to possibly
get into hawaii pierce reacts to it
my dad check her what the highest honor
after me weeping apparently
which i don't because i'm not a child
made this pewdiepie
among us fan art hope you guys like it
sit that looks real almost
very nice i like it hey which one which
chair is that
good meme i see it here good meme oppo
buttons color
reddit it's red it's orange me it's
pewds
hoodie color what what
41 000 uploads i'm so confused get off
reddit please guys
do yourself a favor guard of hell gate
in greek mythology
okay in minecraft he's so cute
alabama shark that's cute that's a good
meme that's a seat here
right there the continent has been
thrown the prophecy will be fulfilled
model s price changes to 69 420 tonight
and that's a great price yeah i saw
people being
so butt hurt over this it's like dude
it's just a joke
i'm sure i'm sure elon know it's ironic
like
so charlie she's like a twilio yeah
that's the joke
have you heard of fun you're the most
control crate you want another
gray-haired overweight
boomer billionaire i don't i think we
have enough of that made
feed it by katana yeah that's right elon
haters
btfo all right made pewdiepie katana i
wanted to make it sooner
when pewds played ghost of tsuchima but
due to schooling covert it was delayed
a little late but i hope you like it
yeah how do you even do that
kind of a photo but that's sick i want
to see you slice some watermelon with it
can you do that
that'd be make an update video let's
slice some watermelon come on let's get
it mr beast and mark it is
every 19 year old who hasn't seen mark
and phyllis collab since years
this is so sad i'm crying tears roses
are red violets are blue shaggy from
scooby doo
is that you all right this reddit is
going
downhill and it's going downhill fast
hey felix i just wanted to let you know
that youtube commented on your video
really but who will be the alphorn mask
oh it's sick
is that real thank you mod team oh
i don't know why they bother asking when
it's clear once i blow this bad boy i
just gotta get it out
there we go i have to go to the living
room
i made edgar bark anger it's okay
when you release today is edgar's
seventh anniversary on pill's channel
what are we blind deployed a happy
birthday vision
edgar's birthday is on the 24th of
october
all right nothing else is worth
celebrating come on ready
everywhere i go i see their face oh yeah
because edgar's terrified
he's actually terrified of [ __ ] i love it
that's that's a weird sense
um we did it boys coco melon is no more
you're done you don't son i sleep
me just scrolling to reddit me realizing
it's edgar's seventh birthday
he's he's like eight or nine or
something i don't remember oh [ __ ]
all right all right the alporn battles
begin what song should i play on the
outboard
that's sick fan art that's big pp right
there i can't upload because i'm not
like that and i can't be bothered but
yeah
god damn well done uh arkan kia
can you guys get normal names hey damn
thank you for the cool fan art i love it
i made it a long time ago
shawn over i'm sorry i didn't see it but
i saw it now
and i bless you with big peepee and so
does come
streamers who don't believe it's him
feelings donating
is it really you
yeah the comments on that video was so
funny let me see it
pewdiepie donuts money streamers he
doesn't donate he's a fake
random streamer is this the real
pewdiepie nah fake random streamer
understandable have a nice day
that shiny hammer looks cool where did
he get it i don't know alpha ammo song
hey pewdiepie hammer that'd be sick let
me know if you want it
because i want it it's dick thunder oh
sh
dick thunder is back again all right
what have you got
i am the empire wait he's got his own
title dude i had no choice but to
respond with the video
need you guys to help all right all
right let's watch it richard joseph
where's the date so i didn't know this
apparently dick is an abbreviation
of richer how how does that make sense
america explain yourself
thunder means nothing without pee-pee
all right it's got a map it's gotta be
around here somewhere oh i got a clue
oh an arrow
could it really be him
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
i guess this proves it all huh
i like this big thunder i'm not logged
in but i would have said
not only is he chad but he was one of
the floor he's below the floor
he's even better all right good me they
laugh at me because i'm different i
laugh at them because they're all the
same
i never said this why i found this in my
all year but
i i'm pretty sure this is someone else's
quote but hey i'll take it yeah i said
that sure
if i'm gonna get in trouble for a bunch
of haven't said i might as well take
credit for
having said as well mom can we have
pewdiepie oh god that is weird what the
[ __ ]
oh i can't look at that hey dave reach 3
million congrats man
well done despite not uploading wait
what's this
it's all coming together now
oh no
this means i have to buy one now it's
your turn
well this is such a like a reaction
inception
so i reacted to him reacting to me
reacting to him yeah i'm reacting it now
i thought it's it's very confusing
someone in the comments is gonna let
everyone know
okay why did i start this
oh god yeah why did you start
well i was well i was i was just
chilling with my little flu
and you were like nah that's not a flu
get this
and i and then i got it now it's your
turn
jesus christ
[Laughter]
okay it is done you may yell louder than
me
saying but you can't play the outport
better than me
ksi it's on oh i'm ready
see avengers all right we'll see it
we'll see it
let's get it is it time no it's not it's
not uploading time yet
i made another pewdiepie among a spanner
it looks like jackaboy is going to die
felix scared irish noises hellos jake
stefano uh nobody what side sees at the
beginning of every video that is
extremely uncomfortable please do not
ever send that video a picture again
okay don't want to see it it's not
edgar's birthday it's soon
you guys can't hold it can you 24th of
october is edgar's birthday and so is
mayas as well
uh sorry felix people need to know the
truth oh no why i forgot about these
it was so annoying they're like just
gotta
get who designed these
designers need to be shot i said it
and i say it again bad design where is
this going
so much
no no
no
[Music]
sweden is irresponsible now
you know the thing that makes you spin
that's a swedish invention
i thought we were good we invented the
dynamite
epic go boom boom oh god
no i'm swedish no more i cannot be
responsible for them
[Music]
hello 19 years i'm anna and i was in
charge of storyboarding bad
history's new pewdiepie video if you
haven't checked it out yet link is in
the dooby doo
yeah i said doobie doo doo doo bye dude
i do but
that must have taken so much work i i'm
so thankful
that you guys chose to do one around me
love it might say i
literally died when she saw edgar and
maya it was so cute
oh god he's he's come back he's been
cleansed
the furby from 2017. we literally
set off the fire alarm in the whole
building and that everyone that it's
like this big office building and
everyone had to leave
i'm sorry i'm sorry those were weird
times
corpse voice with helium right says
voice with sulfur hexafluoride
perfectly balanced as all things should
be i don't think
you wouldn't even be able to hear it
they're so balanced out
no sound would come out you suffer
gaylord
yes that is my actual last name the
first guy to
become his most hated me must have been
like oh
no oh this week is just failure after
failure if this
if this does not work out i'm gonna be
so disappointed oh
god what have i done i gotta see it
there's no way i did it
oh no oh there's no link there's no link
baby that's what i've been waiting for
3500 when it makes the same peepee joke
for that in a row
nice good meme no big peepee though
sorry i won't sing that low
uh mom walks into room what stupid
youtuber are you watching now
the online teacher a good meme
a lot of good memes wait why is it
jumping from 17 to 26 to 17.
are you guys using me what the hell all
right charlie's back again my favorite
youtuber just makeup tutorials
my favorite youtuber just mukbangs my
favorite youtuber
flavored condoms taste tearless oh i see
i'm not your favorite youtuber huh
just wait until i blow this out porn
things will change around here
huh my own subreddit they'll get
uploaded unbelievable
foreign
explaining why he needs to buy all these
tambourines marzia i haven't told her
about the outbourne
this is a problem it all makes sense now
yeah it's so heavy and big yeah
oh damn that's sick
it reminds me of uh the ending of
space odyssey that's cool i like that
is saying you need 20k likes to get into
hawaii me and my 20k alts well
apparently
13k is all it needs now the economy is
low guys
we need more upboards i think that does
it that's it's time
it's time all right
[Music]
um
drone
[Music]
wait i need to play song i'm sorry
neighbors
[Music]
i don't like your shoes
hey
[Music]
oh
look at that definitely worth the
investment
uh so glad i'm so glad i bought this
i'm sorry neighbors i apologize thank
you for watching
another episode of greatest show of all
time
make sure you subscribe so cocomelon
doesn't beat us in subscribers
before i am able to record the video for
the diss track
it's coming smash like if you're hyped
and as always
see you tomorrow breakfast everyone's
favorite moment of video
good vpn sponsor yeah yes i waited for
the north vpn
i know don't worry it's here nor vpn
sponsor
thank you oh let's just get uh let's
just get it out of the way
no savor it all right basically guys
you're browsing the internet without a
vpn
i was recently camping there was a bunch
of public wi-fi
what did i do i slapped on nordvpn and i
could browse
safely but also unrestricted a vpn
helps you become epic that's how it
works right now
there's a 68 discount really they pick
no other number all right you get one
additional month for free you heard this
i'm saying it again and you love it so
make sure you use the code pewdiepie i
highly recommend using nordvpn i use it
myself
and every time i get to use that it's
like
i'm so glad i had it it's one of those
services oh something's blocked on the
internet
bam nordvpn you're done oh i'm browsing
public wi-fi this isn't safe
bam lord vpn i'm done it's there
it also works on your mobile but here's
even more there
they also have nord pass which is a
that lets you store passwords and also
come up with more better epic passwords
i know floor gang 2020 is an epic
password
but everyone's gonna guess it all right
you need safer passwords
brute force my dude have you heard of it
they're gonna hack you in two seconds
they're gonna hack you faster than you
can say enter code pewdiepie nordvpn get
68 percent off
a two-year plan that's how fast they're
going to hack you unless you have a good
password
so make sure you have saved passwords
and use nord
pass you need these services trust me
okay take care of my ps4
vpn.com oh but felix
i don't know about not vpn can i try it
out
yes yes you can try it out for 30 days
money back guarantee that's right try it
out
you got nothing to lose oh